but did you see that bella thorne was
getting some backlash from her people
yeah dude because she did the two
million and then i guess the backlashes
they changed like the we have it as a
current event
apparently what happened was she there's
an option on only fans to do a
pay-per-view and so
for whatever the cost is you can buy a
pay-per-view and see whatever that thing
is so it's like
on top of your subscription you can buy
this extra thing
and she was saying that she was gonna
post nude photos of herself
on the pay-per-view charging two hundred
dollars for it
people asked her so when you say nude
photos you mean nude nude because
i guess her only fans feed was more of
like her instagram photos
like her yeah provocative photos not
nude photos and people want to see her
nude so they paid the extra 200
on top of their subscription jesus and
then that one
uh the pay-per-view yes so 200 one time
you see this one time yeah
uh i don't know details carry on um but
what ended up happening is she didn't
post a naked photo on there
she scammed a bunch of people a bunch of
people then asked only fans for a refund
they couldn't afford to do the whole
payout and so a bunch of policies then
change because bella thorne
didn't post nude photos so can you do
that to somebody
like wouldn't that be fraud yeah i can't
i mean can you do can you promise
something i guess and not do whatever
i'm is like wait what someone promised
nudes and didn't do it
that's the only fans like who would do
this why because all you're doing is
killing your own career
she's she single-handedly [ __ ] sex
workers how did she do that
because now uh before you could tip
however much you wanted and now the tip
is capped at a hundred dollars
and the price for a pay-per-view is now
fifty dollars and
then also because because they paid two
hundred and
and then also fifty dollars well people
were like oh i'm not seeing her titties
and brush
i want my money back so only fans go
it's going to take 30 dollars to get
money back instead of seven now i guess
it's
actually uh what's happening right uh no
[ __ ] about only fans so what i read was
uh
people aren't only fans the creators now
usually they had a week to cash out from
the last weeks uh like so they get paid
basically every friday
yeah every friday they'll get paid but
now it's going to be once a month
so she [ __ ] some people yeah and she
came out and she
uh tried to say that she was only really
on only fans
not necessarily to make money but to
end the stigma of sex workers she's
doing research for a movie
but did you hear the director of the
movie the director of the movie was like
am not making a movie with her about
only fans i have no idea what she's
talking about
she's kind of [ __ ] right the monthly
thing i unless she posts a naked picture
and yeah
fully redeems herself that's how that's
all you got to do
yeah but even then the new policies are
in place for all these sex workers so
you can't get the same type of payments
she can just refund the money to people
i mean that
is a possibility i mean that's what
they're gonna do but it's gonna take a
hot
second mm-hmm but what i don't wish why
the
two why i promise the two she's gonna
get away with scam
without sending a [ __ ] nude pic it's
a straight-up skill
they paid for it i by the way i'm just
putting it out there only fans
i would 100 go straight nuts out for a
million dollars for the month
zero doubt about it uh-huh if you're
saying in a month oh jack off on the
only thing
me too 100 if you're saying a million
dollars i will jack off every once a
month yep without
hard i'm gonna do it anyways hot
lighting i'll make sure it's good
lighting yeah
we'll film it you know what we'll get
let's
get a four camera shoes cat's feet will
be in the back
i think if you're gonna put up four
cameras i think one just for the face
multi-cam yeah one's gonna edit it
together i think you do a camera from
under so people can get this from
the watch 250 to finish money shot yeah
i
like that man although there's there's
limits now right
uh i mean not necessarily on the content
you put out but
the limits on monetarily what would be
the
lowest amount you would have to make for
the month
for that to happen a male a male oh god
dude i got kids
and they're young yeah i got old kids
who've seen them they're good
i've walked around the house naked
because i forgot they were in the house
the other thing is i'd lose every gig i
have
if yeah showtime's like you're jacking
off for a million dollars yeah
i think so guys yeah like we're gonna
have to separate our ways i lose every
part of my business
i don't have a gig that i would lose so
i'm gonna put it out there
you would do it oh hundred percent for a
million that's hard would you have sex
with your wife on there nah
five mil no not that not five mil
but yeah hear me out here that's a five
mil hear me out here once a month
that's hear me hear me out here one
that's 60 million a year
okay hear me out 60 mil i would have to
ask her
obviously we're gonna we're gonna blur
out her face
but people are still gonna know it's her
because it's
gonna blur out her face but here's my
here's my thing like i don't know if 60
mil is worth
what follows that for her scrutiny
i don't mind whatever anybody says that
i don't none of it
what all right what about this none of
it what about what about
10 million or five mil a month but
you have sex with somebody else with
your wife if you're like hey i'm gonna
make
60 mil but i have to [ __ ] somebody else
on i i'm
again because i i think that ends up
whether she thinks it'll be fine or not
that ends up ruining my marriage and
that's not worth it all right you can
wear a mask
oh but i she still knows i'm [ __ ]
somebody else right my wife does
yeah so that's going to ruin the
marriage so i think all right that's not
but
i will say this i would
for sure uh the other reason i don't
want to have sex
i don't want people critiquing the way i
[ __ ] you know you're going to read the
comments
i'd have to oh no i'd have to if i'm no
way think first of all
creep what's going to pay to watch it
and then leave a comment
what's worse reading the comments from
your comedy special or from somebody
watching you [ __ ]
probably watching you [ __ ] you
dude you gotta be cause you didn't leave
a comment for special anyway
to to pay like it's like a hater on your
patreon yeah but you know what it is
can you imagine someone paying and then
leave a comment you're like
but dude you hate them and you paid me
yeah special kind of hater here's the
thing though like
hmm this is going to sound weird but my
comedy is almost more personal you know
what i mean like
100 if you but also there's not like
you know like if i watch porn this guy's
a professional yeah i'm not like god how
do you do that
like
the only time i ever go what is every
now and then when you watch a porn and
like
the dude has a serious bend like to the
right or left and his dick
i'm like how's that gonna fit like i was
pretty good
more i'm more curious with the girl oh
my god how can she take her yeah like
is that coming directly out the side of
her body
yeah someone i'm like how are we gonna
do that yeah like and sometimes
obviously i'm trying to figure it out
this is the difference between me as a
young man
and an older person watching it
sometimes like the size of the dick i'm
doing math i'm like
well that that has to be up near her
sternum yeah some of it like that how is
that
where does that go and then sometimes
the dick's so big
it's like it's you know it's kind of
it's like so big with a
there's just not enough blood to fill
that thing up yeah dude it's hard at the
base
but then at the front and so he has to
guide it in
i'm like it's like it's like a horse
dick
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son